I I like that introduction guinea pig
the most appropriate answer that so far
put that on your on your author bio so
so I met Tim about five years five years
ago I was right assigned write a profile
of man this is before he done for our
body and and he'd written four hour
workweek and so I my job is to hang out
with him for a week and see whether he
really worked for hours actually he
worked like two hours it was kind of
upsetting to me but but I noticed that
he that he was unbelievably at this
granular knowledge of what was going on
with his body the kind of stunned me and
I talked to kevin kelly and he mentioned
that the first-ever quantified self
meeting they had was just in the living
room of think Gary Spencer Kevin's
Harris and their fortune people showed
up and one of them they're like this guy
Tim Ferriss showed up and no one had
heard of the team at that point Tom he
hadn't written but he did this elaborate
decomposition of what was going on with
his body and all these stats they were
like how are you so so I'm interested
we've been talking a lot about how to
collect data on people how to monitor
our health you've been doing it for a
very long time what got you originally
interested in tracking a lot of
specifics about about your healthier
body the beginning was wrestling so the
collegiate wrestling and I had been born
premature so I have reduced lung
capacity in my left side which means a
few things the most important of which
is a lot of trouble regulating body
temperature so I would experience the
equivalent of heat stroke on pretty
frequent basis which is not good for
wrestling and I realized that I could
game the system a bit if I became very
good at losing body weight before when
and then rehydrating effectively so I
started looking at things like the ratio
of my skin surface area to my body mass
since you know muscle is basically just
keyed
patient tissue and then started
experimenting with using let's say
potassium-sparing diuretics I started
looking at how to lose water weight and
how you could pull water selectively
from let's say subcutaneous tissue to
try to maintain performance so I ended
up becoming pretty good at it and I
would cut from let's say 1 75 to 150 two
in 12 to 18 hours and then rehydrate and
then win a lot of matches and this is
done by everyone at the high levels of
wrestling so that one of the big
scandals of Tim Ferriss lore is this
Chinese kick boxing championship right
here I I cut from 193 to 165 and then
rehydrated and and that is part of the
game when you're in weight weight class
based sports at the highest level so
it's started with that and around the
same time age 16 or so I began recording
all of my my weight training workouts so
i have since age 16 pretty much every
single workout I've ever performed yeah
how old you right now I'm 35 okay right
so it is just like some totally crazy
paper handbook or did it malaria okay
it's paper and develop my own
diacritical marks and hen notations so
that i can track from one session to the
next and controlled variables mostly
rest rest intervals and a number of days
between identical sessions so make a
case it started with the drive to become
an all-american wrestling and then for
the the kickboxing whatnot and then it
extended from there into mental
performance and no tropics and smart
drugs LOL now what what are some of the
what have been some of the effects of
gathering so much data about about your
life what do you notice about what
relationship you have your own health to
noticing what's going on with yourself
there are a few things i think most
fundamentally the the act of measuring
in and of itself makes you more aware of
your decisions so even if you create a
metric that has no practical application
let's just say like every time you walk
into a room you count
number of chairs just something like
that it will make you more aware of your
Shining's in your decision so
fundamentally just makes you more aware
human being which I think has has many
downstream ramifications but getting
really specific for instance about a
year ago I did a test with wellness FX
which is a startup that does blood
diagnostics and they they break down
your lipid profile very very granular
Lee and I looked at a few of the
saturated fat fatty acids and saw that I
was very low and something called
myristic acid and myristic acid can be
found in a sperm whale oil which I was
short on at the time and I can also be
found a coconut oil and so there were
two questions one was why was that a
fishing the second with holiday how do I
fix it right and I want to try to fix it
first so I started taking tablespoons of
coconut oil in the morning and I was
able to completely eliminate my morning
coffee I mean it the difference was so
stark and came so fast it really
surprised me which takes a lot huh let's
see other things would would include
using let's say the 044 looking at sleep
and realizing that my degree of
restfulness or feeling fully rested
depended on my not the total amount of
sleep but the percentage of my sleep
that was REM sleep so I started
experimenting with both tweaking my diet
just before bed but also taking things
like galanthamine or huperzine a both of
which are acetylcholinesterase
inhibitors that have become very popular
on the lucid dreaming forums for helping
to induce lucid dreaming which of course
correlates to REM sleep so I was able to
dramatically change my my sleep habits
and largely eliminate insomnia which
I've had my entire life by using for
instance of Philips go light in the
beginning of the day those would be a
few no and now so you did this
originally pen and paper pencil and
paper in a notebook has it gotten easier
as time goes on because there's been
more modern devices you use any of those
things or what's your way of types of
things you tried uh you know like what
what if what works what doesn't in terms
of in terms of strapping stuff to
yourself you know yep
so many ways I could go with that okay
yeah i think i might want to business I
would say that I I am someone who has if
the peculiar malfunction of perhaps
lacking a self-preservation mechanism so
I'll try to set anything right I've
become a little i would like to think
wiser in my my older years but whether
it's I think the bottleneck is really at
the the I have data and the I have
information information being actionable
that's right right that gap is very hard
to close so if i have a Dexcom 7 device
for instance which is a continuous
glucose monitor that doesn't bet it in
your body right it's an implant yeah so
you it's not very pleasant to put in but
it's not also better there are two
probes that are about yay long and you
put them under your skin and then push
them into your side and then you put it
on like a nicotine patch and it
transmitted to a separate device and you
can watch the actual graph of your
interstitial glucose i would say that
for instance in that particular case I
had the graph another question was how
do I get this data to my computer well
notnot that compatible need to use a PC
and then I get a CSV file or something
like that and again if I Richard which
yeah which is which is challenging so I
would actually take that and then put it
to paper and I have found other tools
whether they're very very simple like
the lift app which is for behavioral
modification or slightly more complex
with the social component like the Nike
FuelBand sure that's one of the best
interfaces I've seen actually what what
makes it so good it's intuitive it's
intuitive and it is easily graspable by
people who are not self-identified
quants yeah yeah most people do not like
math and if story and I mean close
reasons I went to Princeton for godsake
was to quit the math requirement one of
the few places that didn't have a math
requirement and embarrassing the true
and here we are but the I think there
are a couple of gaps in the technology
that I expected we get fixed the next
five years with this blood monitoring
you did what what could you
learn about about about your body from
that I mean were there any surprises and
in the in what you observed about your
eating and how it how it affected your
blood sugar is one of one of the one of
the pieces that was most fascinating to
me was how long it took a meal to really
create a peak in my glucose levels and
what that led me to change for instance
which was very practical and this was I
was able to do this after a week or two
was instead of taking a post-workout
shake this is very common like in the
lore of a body building there even
studies that seem to buy correlation to
support consuming protein after you work
out well if the amino acids if you're
combining let's say multi dextran are
hitting you at a peak 60 minutes later
you should actually probably take it
before your workout depending on the
type of workout you do so I started
taking my post-workout shaking before my
workout and my gains just took off
because stuff was taking so long to get
into your system that right so by taking
it by timing it properly I was I was
able to have a maximal anabolic effect
during the window within which I had
maximal insulin sensitivity among other
things and glue for receptors are at the
service of muscle cells and so the
timing I think the technology more than
what to do when to do mm-hmm this is
where people can apply things perhaps
now as opposed to waiting it can help a
lot the time in question now there is a
great anecdote in the middle of your
book where you're talking about about
being at a date and you're uh and and
you're getting along really well with
this woman and the great Chater and then
you basically go please don't let this
weird you out and you pull out your
scale food scale and begin measuring
your food which as you say is sort of
serial killer behavior and things went
downhill from there you never saw her
again so um you know with with that as a
tab on the table um is there it what are
the kind of the social inhibitions
towards being a quantified self person
and and do you think those are sort of
surmountable basically are we just going
to be a nation of serial killers you
know yeah
I'm holding our there's two things that
I'm not sure in the piece that made it
even stranger so not only did I pull a
scale out of not my backpack but I have
this weird like murse man purse thing
which was like another red flag right
and then number three was the reason I
was waiting all my food is I was on this
this this quest for fatness I was trying
to disprove the calories in calories out
model right so I was trying to consume
you know seven times my resting
metabolic rate in 12 hours or something
and she yeah I was just way too much I
don't blame her so to the to the
question of whether you know all people
who are involved with quantified self or
just doing self-tracking will appear to
the outside world as people with you
know tinfoil hats on yeah I don't I
think there will always be plenty of
those people sure but I think that we
will very soon get to a point where
we're already at a point where
self-tracking is opt out whether it's
geo location or otherwise and I think
certainly as the technology progresses
once we have once continuous continuous
monitoring through whether it's implants
patches or something else become the
norm people will stop even thinking
about it a self-tracking it will just me
what you do what's the weirdest thing
you've tracked about yourself weirdest
thing I've tracked that's a good
question I know it it is entered it
during that quest for fatness and I
actually outdid myself with that
recently i consumed fifteen thousand
calories in 20 minutes Wow and then had
close to 30 meals the next day and
clocked in with lower body felt the next
day but that's for the that's for the
4-hour chef which is the next one but
the the weirdest thing I tracked to try
to identify calories in versus calories
out I had to look at excretions actually
measured my poo for a while in grams and
before and after the question that I'm
certain is on the mind of our audience
how do you do that
so for those of you who want to try this
at home it's not very fancy first of all
caveat you do not put on the scale don't
do that right you need you need a
container of some type and then it's
pretty self-explanatory i recommend
grams i'll leave it at that all right
good moving on yes um and and and you
know I do this that you don't have any
the perhaps related to that is you know
something something you talk about your
book is and we've talked about is the
question of and you alluded this earlier
you know whether the amount of
information that's now possible to track
about yourself is brings wisdom brings
knowledge or is just paralyzing it is so
to TMI you know yeah what what what have
you found you have you been able to
detect any sweet spots in in how to
deliver information to yourself that it
that that allows you to use it and not
be sort of just you know awestruck or or
or annoyed by the amount of it yeah I
think I think they keep the cornerstone
concept that I well at least I strive to
embrace I think would be very valuable
for companies to embrace also is the the
the idea of the minimal effective dose
what is the least that we can get
someone to do that will lead to the
downstream behaviors that we want so how
do we Trojan horse in let's say giving
them what they want I'm sorry selling
them what they want then given what they
need or if someone has to lose 150
pounds starting them off with 30 grams
of protein within 30 minutes of waking
up not attempting to change their meals
not asking them to exercise trying to
give people too many choices and too
many actions i think is why most
self-tracking fails so really striving
for minimalism results in less is more i
think one of the types of things that
you think we're going to see people
tracking in the next couple years means
i'm as you pointed out some of the stuff
is becoming very mainstream now we've
seen a lot of stuff i mean the amount of
people I've seen the fitbit's here at
this conference is is huge that stuff is
coming normal what what what if you what
what a couple things that you think you
might you
from the people you've seen where
acceptance is moving where the tool sets
are moving that'll be the next few
frontiers I think given the prevalence
of type 2 diabetes and whatnot certainly
cardiovascular disease I think that
we'll see you already have home testing
kits for things like hemoglobin a1c it's
basically three month running average of
fasting glucose it's not quite that
simple but basically I think people will
whether it's using let's say light
lasers much like a pulse oximeter or
some type of non-invasive sampling blood
glucose I think or interest interstitial
glucose what will come come to be very
common very very quickly as soon as we
get past the pinpricks yeah and beyond
that what you talked about the
difficulty the difficulty of measuring
some things that that you know mood
cognitive function stuff like that these
are very interesting people but how do
you measure things like that why is that
enough that's up tractable he's found
any way to measure it yourself I think
if you have something that is largely
subjective like mood before I ever track
something and determine how to track it
i want to ask myself how will i act on
the data and if not i don't i don't even
go for it but i'm very objective driven
that way i think that with mental
performance there's going to be a lot i
think that that's dependent on the
development of the software so for
instance i'm actually funding a fun
funding a study right now at UCSF which
is looking at using devices like the
Kinect and the ipad for improving
cognitive function and whether that's
working memory or other facets of
executive how do you do that like what
you know so looking at the amount how
the amount of information that you are
given determines reaction speed and then
how you can improve that over time how
you can look at they're actually
separate studies being done within the
same lab Adam ghazali is heading this up
there's a good there's gonna be some
fascinating stuff coming I think once
people see the promise and they can see
the before-and-afters right and even the
mitigation of things like dementia by
using now readily available tools like
touch screen iPad yeah that's when
software developers will be financially
incentivized to create the right
tracking yes I mean currently we have
things like dual n-back training you
have
things like Lumosity and so forth they
give can give you certain data sets but
I'm very optimistic about the cognitive
function partially because mind and body
are sort of one in the same to me right
now it's just another organ sure but
it's far as things that are very
difficult that I wish more people would
track I think fertility metrics would be
way way up there so a sperm motility
count etc I think is something that
people should really really measure as
an insurance policy but I'm not here to
be the insurance police if there were a
company that can make that easier I
think it'd be a huge market for it and
all that I think we can move on to the
questions and answers now we're at the
20-minute park we got the microphones
back there excellent anyone got
questions for Tim throw it out I Tim
love 24 hour body and I think you've
been artists before that have you ever
have you thought about doing a nap and
exercise app which detail stuff and is
anything in a pipeline because I look
stupid in the gym with your great big
book unless you're next you can do lat
raises with two copies of the book is
everyone I have so I do currently have
some a test drive app on Android sooner
than iphone and related to the 4-hour
body for tracking purposes I think that
for our body when it's when it's viewed
a survey cheers your adventure book can
be very useful so a little bit certainly
if you're looking at it as a 600-page
book it can be really overwhelming so
the I do have something in the pipeline
and it's actually in collaboration with
the the lift guys so lift was incubated
with an obvious corporation so they've
and biz and those guys for Twitter and
it's very simple you you establish a
habit and then you just click yes I've
checked in I have accomplished this
habit and then there are a number of
interactive dynamics so i'll be doing a
four-week challenge of sorts related to
the 4-hour body and i think that it will
be a very good test and i hope
illustration of how very little
prescriptive information can catalyze so
pretty awesome changed there may be some
other facets that I can't talk about
just yet that'll make it particularly
interests
but I'm hoping that'll be a pretty huge
data set will say we have an online
question how long until trackers are
internal will you be the first to sign
up well I mean given that i've had stuff
plugged inside of me already i I could
be one of the first to sign up it really
it depends on how well I understand the
risks I mean I've done everything from
flying in stem cell growth factors from
Israel and injecting them up and down my
spine with platelet-rich plasma so as
long as I feel I understand the science
well enough then I would be happy I
would have to be happy to do it I think
we're talking about you know right now
and certainly within the next 12 months
there'll be a lot of that huh okay we
have a couple more questions we won back
there thank you I'm curious if in all
your attempts to track your responses to
exercise and training regimens and diets
did you evaluate any breath gas analysis
your changes in oxygen Co to Co h2s etc
yeah it's a good question I so what one
of the challenges has been for me / a
military test measures and what I can
travel with which is part of the reason
influence so squirrelly it I have done
some gas exchange work looking at vo2
max did that both at Stanford where way
back in the day I think this 2005 I was
actually a test subject for the glove
which is a cooling glove which has some
interesting military and sports
applications it's really fun you get
dressed up in full full gear military
gear with a weighted backpack in March
to heat exhaustion in a sauna I totally
recommended I so it did vo2 max testing
for that I also did some gas exchange
testing at the sports science institute
of South Africa which is one of the most
impressive facilities I have ever seen
in my life that's where I also did
muscle biopsy testings that my legs cut
open and you know bits of muscle tissue
removed I'd like to do more of it is the
answer it's just something that I need
to travel to a dedicated facility for so
I have less of an opportunity
okay well yeah I'd love to I'd love to
carry some stuff around them ideal for
that all right we got one more question
from do we have another one here all
right tom all right so so um one of the
interesting things to me is how so your
books are done really well they've been
bestsellers but you also have this
movement of people who are incredibly
passionate about the stuff that you have
codified and we have wired we have now
about 10 people following your four hour
body a kind of diet for various reasons
I'm curious what you've learned in you
know that's not the usual even even
among kind of people who had best
sellers that they don't usually start
movements yeah so I'm wondering what
you've learned in terms of having this
community of people behind you and kind
of championing or you be in their
champion yeah it's a good question i
would say that I've learned a few things
I do think there is a framework for
behavioral change I've looked a lot at
what BJ Fogg is done and elsewhere but
you can give someone a prescription and
if they don't take the pill the
prescription doesn't matter so how do
you get people to take the pill is the
the puzzle that I've really tried to
crack and I think there are a number of
ways that you look at it first of all
you Jack you address the most common
objection objections and identify the
sticking points that they will hit for
instance I tell people you will probably
plateau between six and eight weeks on
this low carb diet you take a week off
of pag you back off you do this and
that's how you get back on to an upward
trend on the graph and I tell them what
to expect and I address the the issues
that they've read about preemptively so
I think that in addition to that
encouraging people to self track and
share the results it has a
self-perpetuating nature to it I think
those are a few of the reasons that it's
been not only read but adopted by so
many people and
well that speaks of the normalizing I'm
talking about earlier but you have this
sort of serial killer phenomena if you
if you know as more people do it and you
to a certain extent your book is given
them permission to do it right yeah yeah
absolutely I would also say that just
just to talk about the you have to get
someone's attention before you can give
them certainly a prescription or get
them to take action so you know I have
this sort of reputation for being very
hyperbolic and PT Barnum like and it's
absolutely by design that's how I get
people in the gate and that's how I get
the attention so that I can give them
the Trojan horse that then helps all
their blood markers but I don't sell
blood markers I don't sell cholesterol I
don't sell fasting glucose I sell six
pack abs i sell 15 minutes and all this
stuff and then people say guess what I
used to be on insulin and now on that or
whatever it is but that was the goal all
along but I have to sell them something
else and I think that it's very easy to
take sort of a hybrid academic approach
to this where if your goal is to impact
the highest number of people possible
it's very important to understand how to
message properly and it's also fun all
right well thank you Tim for taking the
time to come here and talk if you are
interested in reading more about it for
our body is on on the bookshelves now in
another book coming out right yeah for
our chef next month on the accelerated
learning and everything related to skill
acquisition terrific thanks a lot